شكرا لليال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى
هذه التغطيه المستمره من العربيه لاخر
تطورات الميدانيه في السودان حيث نفت
الخارجيه المصريه ما اثير حول مقتل مساعده
ملحق العسكري المصري في العاصمه السودانيه
وكان الجيش السوداني قد سحب البيان الذي
اعلن فيه مقتل المسؤول المصريه
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر العربيه ان عمليات اجلاء
المصريين من الخرطوم واندرمان ستحتاج الى
المزيد من الوقت مشيره الى ان القاهره
تعمل مع الجيش السوداني على ممرات امنه
لنقل رعاياها من الخرطوم واضافت مصادر
العربيه ان مصر تتوجه نحو بدء عمليه اجراء
مواطنيها عبر ميناء بورتسودان واضافت
مصادر العربيه ان هناك اصابات بين
المصريين في السودان منها اصابات متوسطه
وقد صرح انتوني بينكن وزير خارجيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان واشنطن
على اتصال مع اطراف النزاع في السودان
بهدف ايقاف القتال بشكل نهائي والعوده
للانتقال المدني
مستمرون في التواصل بشكل مباشر مع الجنرال
برهان والجنرال حميدتي للضغط عليهم بهدفي
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار الى وقف دائم
للقتال والذي يمنع المزيد من العنف ويحترم
الالتزامات الانسانيه الشعب السوداني لا
يتخلى عن تطلعاته من اجل مستقبل امن وحر
وديمقراطي ونحن كذلك ستعمل الولايات
المتحده مع جميع الاطراف بالتنسيق مع
الشركاء الاقليمين والدوليين لانهاء
القتال والعوده الى الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه
معنى من القاهره السفير جمال الدين بيومي
مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصريه الاسبق اهلا
بكم معنا سعاده السفير في هذه التغطيه
المستمره من العربيه كيف تفسرون هذا اللغط
الذي حصل بين الخرطوم لجهه الجيش السوداني
والقاهره حول يعني مقتل المسؤول المصري
هو للاسف طبعا في حاله هذه يختلط الحابل
بالنابل وليس هناك جهه مسؤوله واحده
تستطيع ان تتعامل معها فتاخذ الخبر اليقين
وبالتالي نحن للاسف ضحايا لاشعه هنا وخبر
هناك وان شاء الله خيرا انما يجب ان نتابع
مع الصمت المطلق لا تعليق الى ان
كاد لنا حقيقه الامور لان غير هذا هيبقى
نوع من ضرب
الاخماس يعني ولكن الجيش السوداني بنفسه
هو الذي اعلن وهو الذي سحب البيان كيف
يمكن تفسير ذلك
في هذا البلد وعلينا ان نصبر انا شخصيا من
انصار ان نصبر في هذه المسائل ولا نتسرع
لا داعي ابدا للتصرف في استنتاج
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه المصريه كانت واضحه تماما في في
ردها لانها نفت ولكن لم توضح الكثير من
التفاصيل بعد ربما اصيب مثلا او غير اصيب
او قتل لا هي النقطه ان الخارجيه المصريه
تعتبر مصدر موثوق لان هي على صله طبعا بكل
وسائل الاتصال مع السفاره والصفاره قادره
اخبار كل اعضاء السفاره والسفاراتنا في
الخرطوم ليس السفاره صغيره
كبريات السفارات المصريه في الخارج
كنا في يومنا الملائم بلد واحد وانا من
الجيل الذي هتفه العالم مصر والسودان
كدوله واحده وانت الان تستضيف في مصر خمسه
مليون سوداني لا نشعر انهم غرباء عندنا
ولا هم يشعرون بالغربه
والجاليه المصريه في السودان
في السفاره
بنحو عشره الاف هي ليست بالشيء القليل
وهذا يعني الكثير بالنسبه الى مصر فيما
تمر فيه السودان حاليا بالتالي
ومنذ ايام ونحن نتحدث ونقول انه هذا امن
قومي بالنسبه الى مصر
كل الاعين ساهره امنيا وعسكريا في مصر هذه
الليالي والايام على ما يحصل في السودان
باي معنى سعاده السفير لو يمكن ان تضعنا
في جو مثل هذه الايام التي يمكن ان تمر
حتى على الخارجيه الخارجيه لحكم خبرتك
السابقه وكذلك بحكم تعطيك مع الامن
والعسكري معنا القريب جدا لذه وانت عندما
تتحدث عن دوائر العلاقات الخارجيه لاي بلد
تبدا فورا بدائره الجوار والجوار هنا
معناه السودان فلسطين
ذات اهم
اخترنا
اعطاه رقم واحد لماذا لانه كان جزء من
الدوله المصريه في جيلي انا ايضا يعني
مساله مش بعيده عن الذاكره او التاريخ ثم
هذا الاندماج الغريب بين الشعبين انا
شخصيا يعني كثير الزياره للخلطوم يعني
اشعر فعلا بان هذا شعب ينظر الينا كجزء
منه
ثم كل هذه المسائل الدخيله للاسف الشديد
تشعر انها مساله ليست طبيعيه الشعب
السوداني
كاغلب الشعب العربيه طبعا لكن لا يتميز
انه شعب يقدر جدا اهميه وادي النيل اهميه
الامتداد شمالا حتى الاسكندريه كما قال
يوما الرئيس ذات ان حدود السودان الشماليه
هي الاسكندريه وحدود مصر الجنوبيه
ده ده شعور حقيقي هو مبني على ليس مجرد
امن استراتيجي او الامن القومي المصري لا
هو شيء يعني في قلب قلب المصالح
الامن المباشر هذا كيف يعني نصرف عمليا في
طريقه التعاطي المتوقعه مصريا وهي الان
منخرطه في محادثات مع السعوديه والامارات
والولايات المتحده كما قالت اخر المعلومات
لمحاوله ايجاد حل ما السقوف التي يمكن ان
تقبل مصر او لا تقبل بان تتخطاها في اي حل
مرتقب بين الطرفين النزاع
وان
ما هناك بحيث نحافظ على اولا كيان الامه
والدوله السودانيه لان لاحظ السودان انفصل
عن مصر ثم هذا السودان الذي انفصل عن مصر
انقسم الى سودانيين من الشمال وجنوبي كل
السودان منهم مهدد بانقسام داخلي شرقه
وغرب
وهذه لكي يقرب لك المعنى وللساده
المشاهدين هي ظاهره قبليه افريقيه نحن في
في مصر في بعض البلدان العربيه ذات الاصول
التاريخيه المستقره نشر انني مصري سواء
كنت من الاسكندريه او من اسوان لا في في
للاسف في افريقيا يقول لك انا من الهوسه
او انا من الكريبي او انا من قبيله كذا
شعور نحو ولاء العالم واحد بيتراجع وده
للاسف هي الازمه اللي موجوده في ليبيا
موجوده في سوريا موجوده ولكن بشكل حضاري
شويه في لبنان ثم هي موجوده في اليمن
والسودان
الولاء للاسف بيرتفع الى القبيله
الحكومه مضطره الدوله مضطره لان يعني تتخذ
مواقف معينه
ومصر يعني بمؤسساتها التقليديه مؤسسات
دوله تتعامل مع مؤسسات دوله في دول اخرى
ولا تقبل بالتحركات يعني قد لا يكون معنى
لها او بانقلابات بشكل مباشر لا تعترف بها
تعترف بالدوله
يعني ما تفرز عنه الانتخابات في دوله ما
والى ما هنالك في هذه الحاله الان هناك
انقسام عسكري هل موقف القاهره
واضح مئه بالمئه بالنسبه اليك على الصعيد
السياسي للجهه التي يجب ان تقف معها او
تدعمها هل من صالحها يكون ان تدعمها
عسكريا او لا او يعني تلتزم الحياد المطلق
نحن نشجع في مصر دون ان اكون جالس للانف
وزاره الخارجيه نحن نشجع الالتفاف حول
الدوله علم واحد وان كان هذا السبيل اليه
هو الانتخابات فليكن ان كان السبيل هناك
سبل اخرى بالمناسبه لان يعني احد وزراء
خارجيه نيجيريا في يوم من الايام قال
نيجيري ايضا مقسمه بشكل
منزل اذا اختلف كل القبائل فان الجيش في
الاخر هو الفئه الوحيده التي يكون ولائها
للوطن ليس الى
[موسيقى]
اسود وابيض او
لكي تقسيمات اللي احنا بنسمع عليها
ساعات سفير في موضوع الاسرى اللي صار ان
شاء الله يكون انتهى الى غير رجعه
وبالتالي علاقه مصر بقوات الدعم السريع
تاثرت جدا كما كان يفترض على الاقل
بالنسبه الى ما اراده الناس ثانيا الان
موضوع الاتهام الجيش لقوات الدعم السريع
باستهداف سيارات
المسؤول مساعد الملحق العسكري المصري في
السودان الذي قيل اولا او قتل ثم تراجعوا
عن ذلك بس عفوا سعاده هل هذا يجب ان يؤثر
هل هذا يجب ان يؤثر على علاقه القاهره
بقوه يعني بطرف على حساب طرف اخر في
الصراع الان
لا نحن
من يكون ولاء لبلده
اذا اضر ببلده قبل ان يضر بمصر يعني يجب
ان نتخذ منه موقفا ايا كان هذا الموقف نحن
مع من يساندون دوله سودانيه موحده مستقله
رافعه وللاسف ان ده في مدى المنظور
يؤسفني وانا رجل متفائل بطبعه الا تكون
متفائلا في هذه النقطه في انقسام في
السودان بين طوائف بل بين عائلات
الان لدي انقسام اخطر انقسام يهدد السنوات
داخل الجيش الواحد الجيش العالم واحد
ولنفس الملك يبقى فيما يتعلق بمصر الجنود
والمسؤولين والناس اللي في السودان كيف
تفرق القاهره الان بينما هو استهداف
للقاهره لمصر يعني رمزيا وما هو تداعيات
صراع بين طرفين بكل ما حصل حتى الان
من
اي اها ربما تكون حادثه ربما تصرف من ظابط
او كندي في الموقع مهما يكن انما انا
مبسوط انك معي لاستفيد من خبرتك
الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه التاكيد على
استمرار البعثه والمكاتب الفنيه المصريه
في القيام بمهامهم وسط ظروف في غايه
التعقيد كما قالت الخارجيه المصريه الان
ما الدافع لذلك مع كل ما تعانيه مصر
المصريون في السودان الان
الشباب وما قلته ان السودان جزء من مصر
ونعتبر جزء من مصر يعني انا قلت لك انني
من الجيل الذي هدف لعالم واحد انا حتى في
الستينيات من القرن الماضي كان رئيس اتحاد
طلاب جامعه الاسكندريه الذي درست فيها
محمد عبد العزيز سوداني
بعد كده بعد الانفصال وانا
عضو
فيست وسعد جدا انني كنت هناك اقول لك مظهر
من مظاهر الوحده العربيه الجميله لانني
عندما خدمت في رومانيا كنا في السفاره
العربيه الوحيده وكان سفراء الدول او
رؤسائها زاروا رومانيا يفيدون الى الصفار
المصريه وانطلقون منها كانها سفاره هذا
البلد حتى رؤساء الدول فبالتالي
يعني مصر عندها قدره استيعاب بلا حدود
لمثل هذه الامور سؤال المستوى الشعبي او
الرسمي لان هذا موجود بس عندما تقول ان
السودان جزء من مصر ارجو ان يفهم ذلك بعد
الصعيد العاطفي فقط
والتاريخي يعني سيظل السودان في اعيننا
وفي قلوبنا ولا نقبل ابدا ان يكون السودان
محل تهديد الامنه لان امن هذا البلد امن
ليبيا امن فلسطين كل هذا في عمق الامن
القومي هل على الامن المصري مما يحدث في
السودان
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد
ارهاب تسلل المتطرفين
من كل النواحي المياه التعاون في موضوع
السد العالي للتعاون في موضوع تقسيم النيل
السودان لو فضل انه هناك ما يسمى بسلفه
مياه الليل نحن نحصل على جزء من حصه
السداد ب 100 جنيه ونستفيد بها في مصر
لانه دوله امطار يمكن لا يحتاج عشرات
الاشياء تمثل لنا اهميه قصوى ومن اهمها
الحياه النيل والذي يربط هذين البلدين
السؤال الاخير ما الذي يمكن ان يجعل مصر
تقرر ان تتدخل عسكريا في هذا الصراع
الحمد لله لاقرب في في رؤياي وانا قلت من
دقائق غير متفائل لكن لا ارى ان الامور
يمكن ان تتدهور لدرجه ان مصر تحتاج
للتداخل عسكري ضد السودان ولم يحدث ابدا
ان كان الجيش المصري مطلوب ان يتدخل ضد
دوله عربيه اطلاقا ولكن هو حل هو موضوع
سوداني سوداني سوف نساعده
بالمصحف الاخوي السياسي او بتقديم المعونه
العسكريه الذين للطرف الذي يحتاج اليها
شكرا جزيلا سعاده السفير جمال الدين بيومي
مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصريه الاسبق من
القاهره على هذه المشاركه يعني اخذنا راحت
الاسئله بما انك متخفف من التزاماتك
الدبلوماسيه لانه منصبك سابق الان مع كل
ما يعني ذلك عندما يكون المسؤول في منصبه
في الخارجيه شكرا لك على هذه الاضافه
وتحياتي اليك نتابع فيما لدينا في هذه
الساعه من التغطيه المتواصله بشان
الاشتباك ات المتواصله اذا بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تواصلت في
يومها العاشر اعداد القتلى وصلت الى اكثر
من
427 شخصا اما المصابون فهم بالالاف معظم
دول الغربيه اكملت اجلاء بعثاتها
دبلوماسيه من السودان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي قال ان لدى بلاده خططا لحمايه
سفارتها في الخرطوم مشيرا الى ان واشنطن
لا تخطط لنشر قوات حفظ سلام في السودان
دول العالم تسابق الزمن لاجلاء رعاياها في
السودان في وقت تتواصل فيه المعارك
الداميه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع لكن
امال السودانيين في انهاء الحرب تتقلص
ويتسع حجم المخاوف من طول امد الحرب
تقديرات محليه ودوليه اعتبرت ان هذه
العمليات دلاله واضحه الى موجه عنف مقبله
وهو ما يراه السودانيون دليلا على غياب
افق الحل السياسي في البلاد واستمرار
النزاع الدائري ليصل امتداده الى الاحياء
السكنيه
رساله المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب
واسكات المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث
عن الحل السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري
لهذه الحرب وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال اخراج
مواطنين لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك
تراه انت تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج
مواطنونا ومن المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل
كدبلوماسي لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو
اخراجهم
اصوات اطلاق الرصاص وداوي الانفجارات يطغى
على دعوات التهدئه ويزيد من تعقيد عمليات
اجلاء الرعايه المحاصرين بين الجانبين
المتحاربين رغم تعهدات دوليه واقليميه
باسكات البنادق والتوصل الى تسويه سياسيه
سلطان العربيه
[موسيقى]
تحركنا من منطقه الخرطوم الى منطقه على
بعد حوالي 1200 1300 كيلو ايش كثير صعب
انك تخرج من بيتك
نقطه يعني كثير
تحت القصف كان يعني خلص كنا متحضرين حاله
ان الموت يعني باي لحظه
وبينما تستمر عمليات اجراء الرعايه
الاجانب من السودان مع استمرار المواجهات
قال لواء بحري ركن صلاح بابكر عمر قائد
الفرقه 101 مشاه في البحريه السودانيه
للعربيه قال ان هناك تسهيلات لاجراءات
دخول سفن اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب حاولنا
نسهل كل الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالمواني بدخول السفن
ورباطه وايضا بوصول الرعايه هنا وتجميعهم
وضيافتهم وما الى ذلك من من اجراءات حقيقه
كانت عمليات الاجلاء يعني بطريقه سلسه جدا
سهلنا كل الاجراءات حتى الاجراءات الرسميه
للجوازات
والجمارك كانت في مكان استقبال هذه
الجاليات الان احنا بصدد عندنا الان بتحمل
ثلاثه سفن اللي هي سفن من المملكه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعندنا سفينه هنديه
وعندنا سفينه كوريه جنوبيه وفي انتظار عدد
اخر من السفن حقيقه
هذا وضع الامين العام للامم المتحده جميع
الاطراف في السودان لوقف العنف وخفض
التصعيد وعدم استهداف المدنيين والعوده
لطاويله المفاوضات
القتال في الخامس عشر من ابريل قتل مئات
الاشخاص وجرح الالاف يجب وقف العنف والذي
يهدد بمساه في المنطقه كلها ادين القصف
على مناطق المدنيين وادعو جميع الاطراف
لوقف العمليات في المناطق المسكونه انا
على اتصال مع اطراف الصراع وادعوهم لخفض
التصعيد والعوده لطاوله الحوار
داخل القوات المسلحه والان
يبقى
انضم للدعم
هم فره
القياده اصلا لانهم رافضين لهذا الامر
علاقته صداقه وتحالف جمعت محمد حمدان وعبد
الفتاح البرهان بدات منذ نحو 20 عاما
عندما قاتل الطرفان في خندق واحد في معارك
دارفور وازدادت هذه العلاقه متانه مع
التطورات السياسيه في السودان وصولا الى
اسقاط حكم البشير لكن لا شيء ثابت في
السياسه فاصدقاء الامس صاروا اعداء اليوم
وانتهت العلاقه بمعارك طاحنه بين الطرفين
وصل احمدتي الى ولايه نهر النيل زياره
خاصه الى منزل البرهان استقبال بحفاوه
ونقاش حميمي حول مستقبل السودان
هذه الصور كانت قبل نحو عام حليفه الامس
صراع عدوين فلا شيء ثابت بالسياسه
[موسيقى]
قبل نحو 20 عاما كان اللقاء الاول بين
قطبي الصراع في السودان التقح متي
والبرهان في دارفور قاتلا في خندق واحد
بعد 12 عاما تشاؤل اقدار ان يتقاطع طريقا
الرجلين مجددا
ويتفقا على ارسال قوات مشتركه من الدعم
السريع والجيش للمشاركه مع قوات التحالف
في اليمن كل القوات النظاميه قوات مسلحه
دعم سريع شرطه جهاز امن كل الوحدات
النظاميه علاقه برجل واحد
تعززت العلاقه بين احمد والبرهان لتصل في
العام 2019 الى دعم الحراك الشعبي للاطاحه
بحكم البشير
نا هي وحده وتماسك السودان
واليوم ينفرط عقد التحالف بين حميتي
والبرهان فالسودان كاي سفينه لا يمكن ان
يقودها قبطان
من لندن عمار حموده القيادي بالتجمع
الاتحادي وناطق الرسمي لقوى الحريه
والتغيير بالخارج اهلا بكم معنا استاذ
عمار في هذه التغطيه ما هو موقفكم الان
مما يجري
مرحب بكم
السودان الصابر الصامد في هذه المحنه
الصعبه التي لم تمر على تاريخه الحديث
ابدا نحن قوه سياسيه ننتهج الحلول السلميه
انجزت ثوره المجيد عبر السلميه
وضد الحرب تماما ضد اراده الدماغ
السودانيه ما يجري الان هو مساله
الدعم السريع من خلال بعض قياداتكم في
الداخل على الاقل لكي يقوم السيد حميد
بمقامه به لكي يعني نختصر المقدمات وندخل
في صلب الموضوع ما رايك ولكن هذا قول مضحك
جدا حتى الذين يطلقونه لا يكادون لان ما
تقدمت به الحريه والتغيير هو حل شامل
ومتكامل وخطه موضوعه بحيث ان نصل الى جيش
مهني موحد تدمج فيه قوات الدعم السريع واي
قوات اخرى داخل قوات الشعب المسلحه
يعني نكون ظهير لشيء نريد ان ندمجه في شيء
اخر هذا امر يعني احيانا يعني اعاده النظر
فيه تبين انه لغرض اخر والحريه والتغيير
لا
الديمقراطيه لا يمكن ان تسلك الطريق الى
الديمقراطيه عبر الممر عسكري او عبر عسكره
الحال المدنيه لا يمكن ان نصل الى انتقال
ديمقراطي ومدني عبر بندقيه هذا امر لا
يتناقض تماما مع اهدافنا مع طريقتنا مع
البيئه التي يمكن ان تقول
يتحمل مسؤوليه ما حصل الان هل هذا موقفكم
من الذي يتحمل المسؤوليه الطرفين
المتقاتلين يتحملون المسؤوليه مكانه
يتحدثون
عن
هم كانوا يتحدثون على انهم شيء واحد وانهم
جزء من كل وكل يشمل البعض وكل هذه الاوصاف
الجميله فانفجرت الاوضاع فيما بينهم يتم
تحميل الموضوع الى المدنيين هذا امر غريب
ولكن قد يعتبر بانه يعني خيار تحميل
الطرفين المسؤوليه هروب الى الامام من قبل
الكثير معظم السياسيين
لا لا نحن لا ندري من بدا القتال فيهما
هؤلاء انزلقوا في هذه الحرب من غير
يعني احترازات اطلقت طلقه الاولى في مواقف
مبدائيه يا اما بتكون مع قواتك المسلحه يا
اما بتكون مع فصيل في هذه القوات بغض
النظر اما اذا كانت ميليشيات او جزء من
الجيش في قوات مسلحه الان هل هي مسلمه
فعلا هل هي تخترقها الحركات الاسلاميه
التي انتفضتم على حكمها في السابق هل هذا
اتهام واضح للجيش من قبلكم مثلا
سيدي الفاضل لا يمكن لجهه ما تريد ان
تمارس سياسه ان تتحدث
بقوه تحمل السلاح وتشرعنه غير القوى
المسلحه قوات الشعب المسلحه هذا امر مفرغ
منه مساله ان ان هناك فصيل
الجيش السوداني او جيش القوات الشعب
المسلحه احد المرتكزات الاساسيه للدوله
السودانيه ليس هناك سياسي يقول بذهابها او
انه ضدها هذه مساله غريبه جدا ان نتعامل
مع الجيش السوداني وكانه طرف طرف يعني من
الاطراف العاديه لا نحن نتحدث عن انه
الكارثه والمشكله هذه نشات في داخل الجيش
السوداني نفسه
بغض النظر اما اذا كانت اذا كانوا طرفين
او اكثر او طرف واحد لنعتبره طرف واحد
وانشق على نفسه هناك طرفان الان في الصراع
يعني يسمي ذلك خلاف مشروعات او خلاف اشخاص
او ما شابه هل يمكن ان تتخذوا موقفا مع
القوات المسلحه مثلا بشكل مبدئي بانه يجب
ان تقضي على ظاهره قوات الدعم السريع
اذا كان الامر كذلك الان لدينا حركات
مسلحه اتت بالتفاوض
ما كانوا يتفاوضوا معها اصلا يقضوا عليها
لانها تمردت او لانها تحمل السلاح ضد
الدوله هناك نحن فقدنا جنوب السودان هل
ذلك الان هل هي الان او انت تتحدث عن
العصريات السابقه ايام النظام السابق
انا اتحدث عن انه الاسلوب اسلوب حل
المشاكل السياسيه هل يمكنك
في واقع جديد في واقع جديد الان اذا بعض
حركات مسلحه تخلت عن قتالها لا يمكن ان
تحاسبها على الماضي اذا صارت جزء من
العمليه
لا نشجع القتال بين السودانيين اطلاقا نحن
جهه سياسيه تبحث عن حلول سياسيه لمشاكل
سياسيه لا يمكن ما هو الحل السياسي الان
الذي تطرحونه الحل السياسي للغرابه لو
سالت المتخاصمين والطرفين لقالوا لك ان
الحل السياسي ونرجع الى الاتفاق الايطالي
او البحث عن تكمله لهذا الشيء كل يراه من
منظوره لكنهم يؤمنون بان الحل السياسي هو
الاساس
هل يقبل السيد البرهان الان بالعوده الى
متى تحدث عنه بالاتفاق
الدعم السريع
هو الذي قال ذلك الطرفين بلسانهم يقولون
ما يقولونه شيء نعم وما يفعلون شيء اخر
لكن على الاقل الخطوه الاولى انهما مع
الحل السياسي وان هذه الامر عابر والاصل
في الموضوع ان يعود الامر نحن سياسيا نحن
اذا العربيه قابلنا الرجلين لدينا كل
الحوارات نعرف ما قال جيدا جدا انتم معهما
انتم تعاملتم معهما وتعريف تعرفون الرجلين
عن قرب تعرفون مواقفهما وردات افعالهما
تعرفون كل شيء بناء على ذلك نسال لكي نعرف
الموقف على ما هو عليه الان
لم تفيدني كثيرا في تحديد موقف الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي من الطرفين من كل
طرف على حذر حتى لو سميتك
والايجابيات حتى لو سميت نقاط القوه ونقاط
الضعف لا مشكله ولكن ارجو ان افعل ذلك لو
سمحت لا الامر ليس كذلك وضعوا بهذه الشكل
هو الاشكال ان تضع ان هناك طرفين متقاتلين
ويجب عليك ان تقف مع احدهما هذا هذا هو
الاشكال الاساسي الامر ليس كذلك الامر ان
هناك مشكل سياسي اختارت الجهاز العسكريه
هذه ان تحسمه فيما بينها بهذه الطريقه نحن
تحدثنا عن جيش مهني موحد عن اعاده تاهيل
الجيش عن
الوصول الى الى قوميه الجيش كل هذا تحت
مسمى الاصلاح الامني والعسكري وكانت فيه
امور كثيره حينما اسالك اسئله واضحه طب ما
تسمم على من الحق بس عندي سؤال واضح اسئله
واضحه هل الجيش مخترق بقيادات
تعتبر انها صاحبه الحق هل الجيش مخترق
وليس السلاح هل الجيش مخترق
نتكلم بذلك الجيش مخترق عليه ان ان
يحصن نفسه من الاقتراب هذا امر مفروغ منه
اذا كان هناك اختراق للجيش فمعنى هذا ان
هناك فشل هذا امر مختلف تماما انا اتحدث
عن
الجيش مكانه ليس السياسه ما يقوم به الان
من امور سياسيه هو الذي يجعل مثل هذا
الخلط حاصلا بين قوميه الجيش وبين هل هذا
من دوري هل هذا تقولون حتى بان قوات الدعم
السريعه مخترقه او مدعومه من الخارج او
تنفذ اجندات خارجيه وفقا للاتهامات الاخرى
ما يقال عن المؤسسه العسكريه كامله يقال
عن طرفيها ويقال عن اطراف اخرى تحمل
السلاح هذا الامر مفروغ منه يعني
الاتهامات
ومحاوله
اصطفاف تجاه جهه هذا لا يجدي الان مع
يا اخي صاحب القوات بذاتها القوات الشعب
المسلحه بالمناسبه اشكر وجودك معنا انا
يجب ان ننتقل استاذ عمار حموده القيادي
بالتجمع الاتحادي وناطق الرسمي لقوى
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي بالخارج
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه معنا الان
صور من وصول سفينه الى جده السعوديه
وعلمتنها رعايه عرب واجانب الصوره يعني
ليليه وقد لا تكون واضحه تماما بانتظار ان
تجهز او ان تحيطها بعض الاب من الاضاءه
لكي نراها بوضوح اذا وصول سفينه وعلمتنها
من بورتسودان تحديدا وعلمتنها رعايه دول
عربيه واجنبيه تقترب من الرسل من جده اذا
قطعت السفينه البحر الاحمر
مجددا لكي تنقل رعايه دول عربيه واجنبيه
من وترسوا في ميناء جده الساحليه في غرب
السعوديه وهو يعني ما سيكون عليه الحال
يعني في الساعات المقبله لكي تكتمل عمليات
الاجلاء السعوديه بحكم موقعها الجغرافي
اولا وبحكم
اهتمامها الاساسي
بشان السوداني والاقليمي عموما وبحكم
ثقلها السياسي في المنطقه تهتم اولا باول
بكل ما يحدث هناك على الضفه الاخرى من
البحر الاحمر مقابلها تماما حيث تصل هذه
السفن من هناك لكي تقل الرعايه الذين
يريدون مغادره السودان على اثر الحرب
الدائره على اراضيه بين طرفي النزاع دول
رعايه دول عربيه واجنبيه اذا يخرجون تباعا
في وقت باتت تعتقد دول كثيره بان هذا
الصراع رغم كل المحاولات سيمتد وسيطول
سيطول زمنيا وقد يمتد جغرافيا ليشمل بقعه
اخرى او دولا اخرى في
المحيط الافريقي وبالتالي يعني هناك
الكثير من المحاولات الحديثه السياسيا
وعسكريا لكي يعني محاوله درع تمدد هذا
الصراع ووقفه الهدى السابقه فشلت ولكن
محاولات الحل السياسي لا تزال قائمه
بقياده عدد من الدول وعلى راسها السعوديه
والامارات ومصر والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في الجهود الاخيره المعلن عنها
اذن مياه البحر الاحمر تتلالا تحت اضاءه
السفينه القادمه من بورت السودان في الشرق
السوداني وعلامتها رعايه دول عربيه
واجنبيه وهي تقترب اذا من الرسوم في ميناء
جده الساحلي السعوديه اذا هذه طبعا صور
تردنا من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وصول هذه السفينه
وسنرقب طبعا
المزيد من المعلومات حولها هذه السفينه
تضم سعوديين وثلاثه عشره جنسيه اخرى اذا
تضم سعوديين وثلاثه عشره جنسيه اخرى
وهناك تصريحات تقول ان السفينه تحمل
104 ليبيين بينهم دبلوماسيون وفقا للقنصل
الليبي اذا هناك تصريحات لمسؤولين
دبلوماسيين ليبيين الان حول هذه السفينه
يتحدثون عن انها تحمل 104 ليبيين بينهم
دبلوماسيون تقطعت طبعا بهم السبل في
الداخل السوداني مع مختلف الجنسيات الاخرى
حتى الدبلوماسيون والبعثات الاجنبيه كانوا
يتعرضون للقصف للاصابات حتى وصلنا الى نشر
الجيش السوداني خبرا عن مقتل مساعد الملحق
قبل ان ينفي
تنفي مصر ذلك ومن ثم يسحب الجيش السوداني
الخبر هذه السفينه اذا تضم سعوديين كانوا
في السودان اضافه الى ثلاثه عشره جنسيه
اخرى هناك دبلوماسيون من عدد من الدول
ينتظرون رعاياهم في قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه اذا حيث تتوافد السفن التي تنقل
هؤلاء الرعايه العرب والاجانب ومن بينهم
طبعا كما قلنا عدد من الدبلوماسيين وفي
هذه الحاله هناك عدد من الدبلوماسيين
الليبيين الذين يصلون في هذه الاثناء طبعا
سفينه الاجلاء السعوديه هذه هي الخامسه
التي جاءت من السودان الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في جده
وطبعا كل هذه المحاولات السعوديه
والاقليميه ستتوالى من اجل استكمال
اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب العرب والاجانب من
السودان بسبب تصاعد اعمال العنف هناك
وبسبب عدم وصول اي طرف من الاطراف الى
اتفاق مع الطرف الاخر مصر كانت اعلنت عن
اجلاء 904 من رعاياها من السودان وفقا
للخارجيه المصريه منذ بدء عمليه الاجلاء
وانه جرى اليوم ايضا اجراء 134 مواطنا
مصريا مع 334
مواطنا برا بالتنسيق مع السلطات السودانيه
اذا المزيد من المعلومات الوارده عن هذه
السفينه هي سفينه تابعه للقوات البحريه
السعوديه وهي سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع اذا
هذه هي السفينه التي تقل عددا من الليبيين
السعوديين والجنسيات الاخرى ومن بينهم
الليبيون نحن نتحدث عن 104 ليبيين بينهم
عدد من
الدبلوماسيين طبعا كان هناك بيان ايضا من
عدد من السفارات من عدد من الدول التي
اجلت رعاياها بحكم توقع امتداد هذا الصراع
زمنيا وهناك مخاوف من امتداده جغرافيا
ايضا ونحن نتابع وصول هذه السفينه التابعه
للقوات البحريه السعوديه اذا نواصل في بعض
المعلومات التي نذكر بها خاصه التي توالت
في الساعتين الاخيرتين ومنها ابرزها كان
نفي مصر مقتل مساعد الملحق العسكري
بالسودان طبعا الجيش السوداني عادوا نفى
وحذف خبر مقتل مساعد الملحق العسكري
المصري السودان بعدنا في الخارجيه المصريه
ولكن هذا ايضا عاد عاد الاتهامات بين
طرفين طرفي النزاع الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
بشان هذا الموضوع هذا هو كان حديث الساعه
او ساعتين
الماضيتين ولكن بعض السفارات مستمره في
عملها
ومنها المصريه صفير مصر قال انه استمرار
البعثه والمكاتب الفنيه المصريه في القيام
بمهامها وسط ظروف في غايه غايه التعقيد
هذه السفينه التي نتحدث عنها ايضا على
متنها عشره سعوديين تم اجلائهم اذا وهي
ترسو الان بميناء جده
سلطان سلايم مراسل العربيه معنا الان
سلطان
سلطان تسمعني ماذا لديك نعم اهلا بك انا
معكم وكما تشاهدون الان تفضل نعم الان كما
تشاهدون وصلت الان في هذه اللحظه سفينه
جلاله الملك ينبع وهي السفينه تقول على
متنها 199 شخص من ضمن او من 14 جنسيه
مختلفه من ضمنهم عشره السعوديين وجنسيات
مختلفه امريكيه وايطاليه وجنسيات عربيه
وجنسيات مختلفه الان حطت رحالها على متنها
199 شخص تم اجلائهم من ميناء السودان من
السودان بعد ان تم اجلائهم برا من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ها هي الان تحط رحالها
بعد رحله استغرقت قرابه 12 الساعه نتحدث
نتحدث انه هنالك جنسيات متعدده على سبيل
المثال الجنسيه الامريكيه شخصين والجنسيه
الهولنديه ثلاثه اشخاص وكذلك من بريطانيا
خمسه اشخاص ومن تركيا شخصين ومن لبنان 45
شخص ومن سوريا 15 شخص من السعوديه عشر
اشخاص والرقم الاكبر هو من ليبيا بعدد 104
اشخاص نتحدث عن جهود كبيره وتنسيقات كبرى
تعمل عليها الحكومه السعوديه مع كافه
الاطراف هنالك في السودان لاجلاء رعاياها
وكذلك اجلال بعض الطلبات التي استقبلتها
السفاره السعوديه في الخرطوم من قبل رعايه
نتحدث على دول مختلفه من المتوقع ان يصل
اعداد الرعايه الى اكثر من 2000 شخص من
جنسيات مختلفه على هذه السفينه كما نشاهد
الان ها هم الرعايه وهذه السفينه الضخمه
التي تقل المياه وتسعه وتسعين الشخص نتحدث
انه خلال اليومين الماضيين اكثر من 157
شخص تم اجلائهم من ميناء بورت سودان نتحدث
انه من ضمن 91 سعودي وسته وستين شخص اجنبي
من جنسيات عربيه وخليجيه واوروبيه اذا
تحدثنا عن فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء
بشكل عام وصلت اليوم في تمام الساعه
الخامسه عصرا طائره اجلاء كوريه قادمه من
مطار برج سودان
الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده
وعلى متنها 39 شخصيه دبلوماسيه كوريه
بمقدمتهم القنصل او السفير الكوري هنالك
في الخرطوم لا تزال عمليات الاجلاء الياء
الرعايه بمختلف جنسياتهم مستمره على مدار
الساعه من قبل القوات البحريه السعوديه
وكذلك اذا تحدثنا من المتوقع من خلال
الساعات القادمه ان تكون هنالك رحله جويه
سوف تصل الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتاكد لكن من المتوقع
وصولها خلال الساعات القادمه كما نشاهد
هذه السفينه الضخمه وهي السفينه جلاله
الملك ينبع ان تعمل على متنها كما ذكرنا
قبل قليل 199 شخص من 14 الجنسيه مختلفه
قبل قليل سوف يكون في استقبالهم قناصلهم
نتحدث على القناصل الموجوده بجده 14
قنصليه متواجده من خلال القناصل ومناديبس
السفارات في جده وفي السعوديه بشكل عام
وصلوا الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
لاستقبال سوف يتم تقديم كافه الخدمات
اللوجستيه والطبيه والاعاشيه لهؤلاء
الرعايه بعد نزولهم من هذه السفينه الضخمه
نتحدث سوف يتم استقبالهم انهاء اجراءات
السفره الخاصه بهم من قبل المديريه العامه
للجوازات وكذلك اداره الجمارك سوف سوف يتم
استقبالهم التاكد من سلامتهم وصحتهم ومن
ثم انهاء كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه برعايه
الواقعين او علامات هذه السفينه نشاهد
الان بعض اللقطات لبعض الرعايه الان كما
يظهر امامكم هم يعني بطبيعه الحال يعني
مشاعر مختلفه يشعرون بها وتحديدا يعني
يشعرون بالامان بعد وصولهم الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده بعد الاوضاع
الماساويه التي تعيشها السودان نتحدث فوضى
كبيره كان يعيشها اهالي السودان وكذلك
كافه الرعايه المقيمين في السودان اليوم
السعوديه تعمل على استقبال كافه الطلبات
والموافقه على بعضها من خلال
واجلائهم برا من الخرطوم الى
مدينه بورتسودان ومن ثم بحرا الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده عبر القوات
البحريه السعوديه لا تزال عمليات الاجلاء
مستمره على مدار الساعه من المتوقع ان تصل
كذلك رحلات يوم غد ايضا ذكر السفير
السعودي في الخرطوم من السفاره السعوديه
تعمل استقبال بعض الطلبات واتمام عمليه
وتنسيق عمليات اجلائهم عبر السفن البحريه
العسكريه السعوديه كما نشاهد يلوحون
بايديهم وهم بطبيعه الحال يعني يشعرون
بمشاعر الفرح والامان والسعاده بعد وصولهم
الى بر الامان هنا في مدينه جده بعد
الفوضى والماساويات الكبيره التي يعيشها
المجتمع السوداني وكذلك كافه الرعايه
العاملين هنالك نتحدث على جنسيات مختلفه
اكثر من 14 جنسيه تعاملت معها اليوم على
متن هذه السفينه ايضا متوقع تتنوع
الجنسيات كذلك خلال الايام القادمه واكدت
السفاره السعوديه في الخرطوم ان عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره على مدار الساعه بالتنسيق
مودات الخارجيه السعوديه وما حكومات
الرعايه هؤلاء البلدان ايضا دقائق معدوده
وسوف ترسو هذه السفينه على على ميناء او
الرصيف الخاص بقاعه الملك فيصل البحريه
سيتم استقباله من قبل اداره الجمارك ومن
قبل مديريه العامه
للجوازات سوف يتم استقبالهم وانهاء
اجراءاتهم ومن ثم بعد ذلك سوف يتم اكمال
عمليه نقلهم الى مساكن خاصه بهم في جده
وفرتها الحكومه السعوديه وانها وتقديم
كافه الخدمات اللوجستيه الخاصه بهؤلاء
الرعايه نؤكد انه السفر السعوديه في
الخرطوم وزاره الخارجيه الحكومه السعوديه
والقياده السعوديه تعمل على استقبال
الطلبات والموافقه على بعضها لنقلهم لنقل
الرعايه الى مدينه جده عبر ميناء بور
السودان اعداد كبيره تجاوزت الالفين شخص
تم نقلهم بحرا وجوا متوقعا تزداد الاعداد
خلال يومين القادمه وتزل عمليات الاجلاء
مستمره كما نشاهد الان الجميع على متن هذه
السفينه ينتظرون بكل شوق وحب ان يصلوا او
ينزلوا الى هذا المرسى او هذا الرصيف
البحري لاستقبالهم من قبل اهاليهم ومن قبل
القناصل الخاصه ببلدانهم الجنسيات مختلفه
كما تحدثنا 14 شخص 14 جنسيه مختلفه سوف
يتم استقباله من قبل قناصل وكذلك عائلاتهم
سوف يتم التاكد من سلامتهم وصحتهم وانهاء
كافه اجراءات السفر في المده لا تتجاوز
الساعه الواحده لا سيما ان كافه الدوائر
الحكوميه المتعلقه بانهاء اجراءات السفر
هي متواجده هنا للتسهيل على على الرعايه
وانهاء اجراءاته في اقرب وقت ممكن سوف يتم
الذهاب بهم الى اربعه فنادق في جده تم
تخصيصها للرعايه طوال اليومين الماضيين
وكذلك 199 شخص سوف يتم ايضا نقله من
الفنادق لاخذ الاستراحه وتاكل من سلامتهم
وصحتهم ومن ثم انهاء اجراءات خاصه ببلدان
تبقى معنا سلطان اريد ان اسالك بس عن
طبيعه
ناصر القوات السعوديه المتواجده علامات
هذه السفينه اكثر ولكن بعد ان نشير الى
بيان من وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه استمرارا
لجهود التي تبذلها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بتوجيهات من القياده الرشيده في
عمليات اجراء مواطنيها ورعايا الدول
الشقيقه والصديقه من جمهوريه السودان الى
المملكه وصل مساء اليوم الى مدينه جده
عشره مواطنين سعوديين كما بلغ عدد رعايه
دول الشقيقه والصديقه الذين تم اجلائهم
نحو 189 شخصا من الجنسيات التاليه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المملكه
المتحده السويد ايطاليا قطر سوريا هولندا
العراق تركيا تنزانيا لبنان ليبيا حيث تم
نقلهم من خلال سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع حيث
حرصت المملكه على توفير كامل الاحتياجات
الاساسيه للرعايه الاجانب تمهيدا تسهيل
مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم وبذلك يصل اجمالي من
تم اجلؤهم من السودان منذ بدء عمليات
الاجلاء نحو
356 شخصا مئه وواحد مواطن سعودي
و255 شخصا ينتمون الى 26 جنسيه اذا هذا
كان بيان وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه حول
وصول سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع الى من
بورتسودان الى جده حيث توفر كامل
الاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه الاجانب
واضافه الى المواطنين العشره السعوديين
الذين يصلون الى بلادهم اذا اما بخصوص
الاجانب ورعايه دول الشقيقه والصديقه اذا
كما قال البيان فعدده منحو 189
منهم امريكيون بريطانيون سويديون ايطاليون
قطريون سوريون هولنديون عراقيون اتراك
تنزانيون لبنانيون وليبيون تم نقلهم اذا
من خلال هذه السفينه
وتمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم يصل
اجمالي من تم اجلائهم من السودان وفقا
لبيان وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه اذا منذ
بدء عمليات الاجلاء النحو 356 شخصا نتحدث
عن مئه واحد مواطن سعودي
و255 شخصا ينتمون لسته وعشرين جنسيه بشكل
عام يعني اضافه الى التفاصيل التي تفضل
بها قبل قليل سلطان الذي اعود اليه لاساله
اذا يعني طبيعه القوات نحن تحدثنا ان
القوات البحريه بتكون عاده مستلمه الموضوع
في اي عناصر من اجهزه اخرى
الجهه المسؤوله عن عمليات الاجلاء البحري
من السودان وتحديدا من بورت السودان وصولا
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هنا بجده هي
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه هي
المسؤوله الوحيده بالتنسيق بطبيعه الحال
مع السفر السعوديه ووزاره الخارجيه وعدد
من الجهات الحكوميه التي شكلت لجنه
للتسهيل والتنسيق ورفع مستوى التنسيق فيما
يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء من الخرطوم اوصولا
برا وصولا الى بورت سودان ومن ثم بحرا الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه كذلك نتحدث عن
تنسيقات اخرى اذا تحدثنا ان وصلت في تمام
الساعه الخامسه عصرا لليوم رحله اجلاء
جويه عباره عن طائره كوريه على متنها 39
شخص من ضمنه دبلوماسيه من ضمنهم بعائلاتهم
من ضمنهم السفير الكوري هنالك في الخرطوم
نتحدث عن جهود كبيره وقوات البحريه ضخمه
تم تسخيرها لعمليات الاجلاء من السودان
الى السعوديه نتحدثنا فيما يتعلق بالعوده
الى الوراء تتحدثنا فيما يتعلق بعمليه
الاجلاب الاولى كانت عباره عن خمسه سفن او
خمس فرقات ضخمه بحريه وهي جلاله الملكه
الرياض وجلاله الملك ابها وجات ملك الجبيل
وجلاله الملك ينبع الملك الدمام خمسه سفن
والخامسه هي اربعه
تموين تقوم بالتمويل هذه السفن الضخمه
وكانت هذه اول عمليه اجلاب بحري من بورت
سودان وكان علامتها 157 شخص من ضمنهم 91
سعودي
وسته وستين اجنبي وصلوا الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في جده خلال اليومين
الماضيين هذه هي الدفعه الثانيه او الموكب
الثاني البحري عبر سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع
على متنها كما ذكرنا 999
من 14 جنسيه مختلفه الاكثر عدد هم مواطني
المواطنين من المواطنين الليبيين بعدد 104
اشخاص وكذلك على متنها خمسه اشخاص من
بريطانيا والشخصين من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الان سوف يتم عمليات نزول هؤلاء
الرعايه بعد تجهيز المرسى او الرصيف ومن
ثم وضع السلالم لاستقبال الرعايه من قبل
القناصلهم وكذلك عائلاتهم وايضا هنالك
علامات هذه السفينه هنالك عائلات واطفال
وكبار سن تم التعامل معهم واجلائهم سريعا
من بورت سودان ومن ثم التاكد من التاكد
لصحه التاكد من صحتهم على متنا هذه
السفينه وكذلك سوف يتم التاكد مجددا من
صحتهم وحالتهم الصحيه بعد نزولهم الى هذا
الرصيف هنالك مركبات اسعاف وعيادات طبيه
تابعه للقوات البحريه للقوات الملكيه
البحريه السعوديه سوف يتم معهم وتاكل من
صحتهم سوف يتم تسخير وانهاء كافه اجراءات
السفر فيما يتعلق بعمليه الجوازات وغيرها
من الاجراءات الرسميه من خلال وجود
المديريه العامه للجوازات واداره الجمارك
وكل القطاعات الحكوميه الخاصه في عمليه
الاجلاء كما نشاهد الان وجود عدد كبير من
قيادات الامنيه للتاكد من وصولهم ونزولهم
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده بكل
يسر والسهول وتبقى معنا سلطان اذا هذا
الصراع القائم في السودان دفع طبعا بعده
دول لنقل رعاياها جوا او عبر البحر كما في
هذه الحاله من بورت سودان الى جده هناك
عدد من الدول من التي اجلت قوات خاصه منها
او قوات عسكريه جميع الموظفين الحكوميين
مثل حالات الولايات المتحده مع اسرهم الى
جانب دبلوماسيين من بلدان اخرى كذلك
جيبوتي كان لها دور ايضا في هذا المجال
اثيوبيا ايضا عندما قامت الولايات المتحده
بذلك بريطانيا كذلك قالت بان القوات
المسلحه البريطانيه اجلت الدبلوماسيين
واسرهم من السودان وتعاونوا في ذلك ما عدا
دول اخرى مثل الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
فرنسا التي قالت انه طائره فرنسيه اجلت
علمتناها 100 شخص غادرت السودان اجلت 100
شخص ايضا ونقلتهم الى جيبوتي
بينما كان من المقرر ان تغادر طائره اخرى
تحمل عددا مماثلا في اليوم نفسه مع
التخطيط لمزيد من العمليات كذلك شملت ايضا
العمليه الفرنسيه اجلاء اعضاء من الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع طبعا التذكير بانه موضوع
مهاجمه الموكب الفرنسي اللي تبادل طرفه
الصراع الاتهامات بشانه المانيا ايضا اجلت
عبر اربع طائرات المانيه حول 400 شخص
وصل معظمهم الى برلين اولا ايطاليا كذلك
اجلت مواطنيها وقالت انها ستجري اخرين
ايضا ستجليهم منهم اصلا من سويسرا ومن
الفاتيكان ومن دول اوروبيه اخرى بمصر كذلك
تحدثنا قبل قليل عن اجلائها المئات من
الجاليه الكبيره في السودان
السعوديه وطبعا بقي الدول الخليج كما
نتحدث الان ونشاهد في هذه الصور مع صور
القوات البحريه السعوديه وهي تؤمن وصول
ورسول سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع في ميناء
جده القادمه من بورت السودان اذا بانتظار
نزول كل الركاب من على متنها
وقناص دوالهم ينتظرونهم هناك لكي يتسلموه
لكي يتسلموهم ومن ثم يواجهوا بالاجراءات
اللازمه من جانبهم او من جانب المملكه
العربيه السعوديه للعوده الى بلادهم مع
يعني طبعا مراعاه كل حاله على حدا طبعا
هذه السفينه السعوديه التي رست بجده اذا
اجلت رعايه نذكر من امريكا من بريطانيا
السويد ايطاليا قطر سوريا
قطر التي قالت ان السعوديه ساعدت في اجلاء
مواطنيها
والكويت كذلك اجلت عددا من المواطنين
الذين كانوا راغبين في العوده الى ديارهم
وقد وصلوا الى جده نحن نتحدث عن سفن حربيه
سعوديه اذا عبر البحر الاحمر
هناك
روسيا ايضا التي اجلت عددا يعني نحو 140
شخصا من اصل نحو 300 روسي في السودان ممن
ابدى رغبتهم في الرحيل اضافه الى عدد من
الدول الاخرى بالامس عرضنا الكثير من
الصور والفيديوهات
والاحاديث من شهود الاعيان عن الاردن
السويد ذلك السفاره الليبيه
اسبانيا الهند تونس لبنان كوريا الجنوبيه
اليابان كندا غانا كينيا نيجيريا واضافه
الى دول اخرى اذا مثل النرويج وايرلندا
وهولندا وبلجيكا الدنمارك المجر سويسرا
النمسا كل هدول اذا يعني اعلنت عن اجلاء
مواطنيها او اجراء مواطنين اخرين اخرين
عبر سفونها وطائراتها نشاهد اذا المزيد من
الصور والفيديوهات لرسول هذه السفينه
السعوديه
في ميناء جده وتحمل على متنها كل هؤلاء
نحن نتحدث عن 104 الليبيين بينهم
دبلوماسيون وفقا للقنصل الليبي نتحدث عن
عدد من السعوديين وعن ثلاثه عشره جنسيه
اخرى دبلوماسيون وقناصل من عدد من الدول
ينتظرون رعاياهم في هذه القاعده قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه وهذه السفينه هي سفينه
الاجلاء الخامسه التي جاءت من السودان الى
هذه القاعده في جده وهي سفينه تابعه
للقوات البحريه السعوديه تدعس في جلاله
الملك ينبع على متنها عشره سعوديين تم
اجلائهم اذا اضافه الى
التفاصيل التي اوردها بيان وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه قبل قليل والذي تحدث عن عشره
مواطنين سعوديين اذا اضافه الى 189 شخصا
من رعايه دول الشقيقه والصديقه من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المملكه
المتحده السويد ايطاليا قطر سوريا هولندا
العراق تركيا
تنزانيا لبنان وليبيا تم نقلهم من خلال
سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع وحرصت المملكه على
توفير كامل الاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه
الاجانب تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى
بلدانهم وبذلك يصل عدد او اجمالي من تم
اجلائهم من السودان منذ بدء عمليات
الاجلاء نحو 356 شخصا نحن نتحدث هنا عن
101 مواطن سعودي اضافه الى
255 شخصا ينتمون لست وعشرين جنسيا نتابع
واياكم هذه الصور اذا لاستمرار التجهيزات
والترتيبات الامنيه واللوجستيه اللازمه
لانزال هؤلاء
الرعايه الاجانب واضافه الى المواطنين
السعوديين من علمتني هذه السفينه
لكي يعني
يصار الى القيام بالاعمال اللازمه
لاعادتهم الى بلدانهم بعدما اختاروا
يعني يذهب ان يرحلوا من السودان بسبب
الصراع الدائر هناك كما فعل المئات
والالاف من مواطني الدول الاجنبيه كان
الحديث في البدايه عن عدم تفكير بعض الدول
باجلاء مواطنها ومن ثم عندما تفاقم الصراع
قررت بعض الكثير من الدول معظم دول العالم
اجلاء رعاياها وحصل الكثير من التنسيق بين
دول متعدده من اجل المساعده في ذلك كما
فعلت المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذه
الحاله عند حديثنا عن هذه السفينه التي
تعتبر السفينه الخامسه وربما سيكون هناك
يعني سفن اخرى تحمل المزيد تحمل المزيد من
المواطنين اذا تمكن تبقى مواطنين سعوديين
هناك او رعايه لدول اخرى يعني
في السودان مع استمرار الاتهامات مع
استمرار الاشتباكات مع سقوط كل الهدن
المعلنه حتى الساعه في السودان للاسف
التغطيه مستمره مع ميسون على راس الساعه
شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات